tell everybody about what you're doing
on youtube now and and how what the
response has been from uh young founders
who obviously look up to you in a
tremendous way
yeah well so on youtube i started
thinking about youtube about a year ago
and i had was making this podcast
i am still called the quest which was
kind of like inspired by my own story of
like trying to go through
being successful and then finding out a
little bit hollow and then you know find
some other things that were more
meaningful to me you know i noticed all
these people had similar stories like
entrepreneurship or like in all these
different categories sports or
entertainment so i started doing this
podcast and then i was trying to hire
someone to like help me promote the
podcast and
i ended up
posting in this gen z server like a
discord server to try to find someone
young to like help me out with it and
um got this response by this woman jen
who's like you know a very young
product manager in tech and she was like
you should have a youtube channel
and it's kind of like i don't know i
don't know if i want to do the work
sounds like a lot of work it is a lot of
work yeah and so
she was like look look i'll help you
make it i'll do all the editing all you
have to do is buy camera and put it in
yourself and tell a story
so it's like okay i'll i'm someone who's
like i'm i'm often very much like a yes
and person i'm like hey let's just try
it out see what happens
so
i said okay i'll try it so
uh bought a camera record a few stories
and she edited them and they turned out
really a lot better than i ever thought
they would and so
we threw them up on youtube and they got
a pretty good response and then i just
had a lot of fun with it so i've been
making videos
ever since for the last almost a year
now and uh it's got a pretty good
response from the
tech community i think you know i'm very
vulnerable and open about like the
things that happen and you know whether
it was shutting down atrium and you know
laying off 180 people or the winds as
well and things i learned things i'm not
good at um
and so you know it's kind of an
experiment but yeah it's pretty cool
because
people
people like it you know i get
a lot of positive feedback i got texted
this morning from
a friend i had on the podcast harry
shuck is the founder of
um [ __ ] up
blank on the name 30 billion enterprise
sas company um
and uh well that narrows it down to 67
yeah what it is right now in this market
so many big companies it says
was texting me and telling me he was one
of his employees he was in his israel
israel office and one of his employees
was like
a huge fan and like said that you know i
inspired her to think she was like if
justin could do it i could do it i was
like that's so meaningful to me you know
like to get that feedback from people
around the world for the content i've
created so really happy to be doing that
and then i've also been making a youtube
podcast which i basically copied like i
watch all in by the way i'm like my
biggest all-in fan i listen to every
episode yeah dude
you figured out you're a great by the
way you're a great
host
and uh
sometimes your co-hosts don't give you
enough credit for it they started to
more recently but like for a long time
they didn't give you the credit for it
so i want to
call that out i appreciate that
it's interesting because
they
the public has been saying like why are
they giving you a hard time about your
moderation skills like you literally
keep the show moving and right as i
think somebody's getting boring or
things dragging you ask a good question
you're pivoted or whatever it just comes
from
having done 1200 podcast episodes i kind
of get a sense of when things are
getting boring
and when to move on to the next subject
but um so yeah all-in is some weird
it's weird how popular it's gotten so
quickly it's like creating a super team
or something in the nba
and it's become more than the sum of its
parts you know
well it's it's really it's funny because
i spent a lot of time thinking about it
because i'm a big fan and i love the
content like um i drive a lot between
northern california and la right so i'll
eight hours and i'll listen to like a
couple episodes on the drive
and um
and then i saw i was like he's having so
much fun doing this or like these guys
look like so much fun so i made a
youtube show like we'll do a show
i've got
three of my other like kind of
yc-related friends yeah yeah like kind
of copy well i was shameless i was like
look i'm just copying
uh who have said the same thing to me
and they're kind of trying to figure out
their quartet and i'm like that's great
get your besties together and do it yeah
because usually just i mean it was
primarily motivated because you guys
seem like you're having so much fun oh
it's hilarious yeah
yeah
but like people don't know behind the
scenes
it's so much work to like if you like
corral your rich friends to get in one
place and have like sound like show up
with like equipment and like no i didn't
upload the videos no i have all the
ideas because i've been doing it now you
know yeah the public doesn't will yeah
with like cyborg michael cybel and
emmett cheers my co-founders of twitch
ceo and like getting people to like
like upload a video on
google drive or like to like have a
headset
you know like it's crazy it's it's it's
surprising how yeah for the first 25
episodes was me trying to get people to
commit
and then sending them headsets and i
just said you know i'm going to commit
to doing this i have my own podcasting
team i got seven people on the
podcasting team between ad sales and
producers and editors and everything
and i said like listen uh just send them
the equipment and if they lose it just
send it to them again
go down
run to their place
you know install the software show them
how to use it walk them through it do a
tech check with them get them to upload
all this stuff and
something happened after the robinhood
episodes and that whole thing
where we had this that whole when robin
hood shut down trading yada yada and
then vlad came on the pod the podcast
went like five or 10x that week
and then friedberg and saks and chamath
i think for the first time got a taste
of what it's like to
you know something you and i have
experienced when you get a lot of
attention at once and everybody starts
talking to you about it and that's when
they kind of clicked into it and i said
if you want to be successful this we
just have to do it every friday you have
to mark off your calendars and tell your
eas and your assistants and your spouses
that time is sack we're saying
you cannot change fridays at 11. and i
would say four out of five fridays they
bought into that
yeah
it's funny about this week number 42
the episode hit number 42 on all podcast
episodes in the world
which is mind-blowing after 55 episodes
or 56 episodes
yeah it's amazing but it's great let's
say you you did a good job of i don't
know if it's like
you just picked your friends who you
would balance each other but you did a
good job of
the origin story
pinged me and said hey i want to do the
podcast and i was like yeah you can go
on this week and start ups any time he's
been on six or seven times
and he said no no i want to do a podcast
with just the two of us so you interview
me i interview you we talk you talk
about startups i talk about late stage
and we just chop it up i was like great
you know we're in the middle of a
pandemic i don't get to see enough great
so we start doing it and then we're like
you know what uh sax wrote something
really good about masks
and then uh we're like yeah and
friedberg talked a little bit about you
know his theories on this and he's a
science guy freeburg didn't have a
twitter handle at the time
and they uh both
came on and then it was like wow this is
really working um and the only thing
that is any debate now i think in the
format is the amount of politics i don't
know how you feel about politics on the
pod but i'll just ask you hey what are
you thinking for people in the chat room
what do you think about when we cover
politics because it's been polarizing
obviously politics is the most
polarizing thing
[Music]
if you don't have business insurance you
failed one of the first steps of being a
great founder startups should look no
further than in broker
broker's technology saves you time and
money prices are like up to 20 lower and
they got better coverage than all these
slow incumbents you can go from sign up
to quote and purchase in just 10 minutes
i kid you not and when you work within
broker instead of business insurance
incumbents you're not dealing with large
slow corporations the sign up takes days
not weeks and the process is so
transparent there's no opaque pricing
there's no negotiation you just get it
all done easy peasy lemon squeezy i'm
going to quickly explain to you one
crucial type of start of insurance that
embroider covers it's called iano you
may have heard it or overheard it it
covers errors and omissions that'll help
you deal with scaling your business and
because any major customer you try to
sign up is going to say hey can you show
us your eno part of the diligence
process if you want to get it now it's
not that expensive these things are part
of the process of growing up as a
startup and you know what i find
sometimes people wait until they get
burned to put on their insurance the
insurance is not that expensive you want
to do it proactively especially if
you've raised money recently that's the
perfect time to deploy a little bit of
capital into protecting the kingdom
protect your enterprise so to instantly
buy custom built insurance for startups
go to inbroker.com
and while you're there you get 10 off
they're already amazing prices by using
the offer code twist twist in broker
e-m-e-r-o-k-e-r-com
twist all right thanks for supporting
the show on broker love you guys